un conflicto sin resolver el referendo
organizado por serbia aumentó la tensión
histórica con su antigua provincia de
kosovo el parlamento del país de mayoría
étnica al banna votó el sábado en contra
de que la minoría serbia con doble
nacionalidad pueda ejercer su sufragio
en solo kosovar mes ofac una práctica
incorrecta de hace años no justifica que
continúe el consentimiento de las
autoridades no puede estar por encima de
la ley ni en la constitución kosovo es
un estado independiente y soberano y
debe ser tratado como tal todos el
partido lista serbias abandonó la sala
antes de la votación mientras que dos
camiones con material electoral fueron
interceptados por las autoridades
kosovares
los serbios buscan cambiar la forma en
la que se eligen jueces y fiscales y
adaptarse a las exigencias de
independencia judicial de la unión
europea la prohibición ha enfadado al
gobierno serbio continuaremos luchando
por los derechos del pueblo serbio en
kosovo y metohija que nadie puede violar
con algunas resoluciones anti serbias
que producen consecuencias imprevisibles
y requieren una respuesta política
decisiva el comportamiento de prístina
étnico en los balcanes se remonta a hace
más de 600 años cuando el imperio
otomano venció una batalla contra lo que
se conoce de forma mítica la gran serbia
la mayoría de la población kosovar es al
banna y musulmana el nacionalismo serbio
considera su presencia como una invasión
ese fue el germen de la guerra entre
1998 y 1999 en la que yugoslavia invadió
kosovo la contienda finalizó con la
intervención de la otan y una década más
tarde en 2008 kosovo declaró la
independencia con el apoyo de eeuu
esta es mayoritariamente reconocida pero
serbia y su aliado rusia se oponen